back in jail a trio accused of holding
two teens captive put into handcuffs
only eight news now was there thanks for
joining us at five I'm Kirsten Joyce and
I'm Brian Loftus now one of the
defendants is a School employee eight
news now investigator Vanessa Murphy has
the latest on the judge's decision to
set cash bail defense attorneys asked
for the trio to remain out of custody
but the judge pointed to material like
body camera video of one of the alleged
victims the teen girl appearing to be
rescued by police and the judge sat bail
Addie Gonzalez learning she's being
taken to jail Clark County District
Court Judge Tiara Jones setting cash
bill at 75 thousand dollars for the ant
accused of holding her adopted niece and
nephew captive and abusing them
physically and psychologically for years
bail for her living boyfriend Daniel
omasgula said at twenty five thousand
dollars and bail for the children's
grandma set at ten thousand prosecutors
say Maria pasaden visited the home
frequently and held the key to the room
where the teen girl was found in
conditions like this including a bucket
for the bathroom this case is bone
chilling it is disturbing the fact that
these two children survived the
systematic abuse for years is just
unfathomable North Las Vegas Police say
they found the girl locked in this room
after neighbors found her trying to get
water last November this is a ladder
from the second floor it is something
that you only see on TV Gonzalez has
been a family learning advocate for the
Clark County School District since 2005.
according to CCSD she's now on unpaid
leave defense attorneys argue the trio
is not a danger to the community judge
Jones disagrees and it is very very very
concerning to the score all three
defendants pleaded not guilty reporting
at the Regional Justice Center in
downtown Las Vegas Vanessa Murphy 8 News
Now Vanessa thank you an update on the
alleged victims prosecutors say the teen
boy has aged out of the child welfare
system while the team girl is in
protective custody and is currently in
high school just in the 8 news now
investigators learning the grandmother
Maria pasarin is now out of custody and
has been given at least 24 hours to post
bail after her attorney argued that she
has health issues that's according to
court staff